so the product of ATA
that's where you multiply
This Matrix and let's transpose you remember what
it transposes a transpose is when where The
Columns of The Matrix?
Become the rows of the Matrix. So
here a if we were if I would
copy this that would give us the original Matrix. We
have up here times.
The same Matrix but it's rows and columns have been stopped now
to multiply these out.
I'm actually going to use numpy because
I don't want to.
Do this by hand?
I will create.
and new notebook
I'm going to bring a numpy.
as NP
and so we have a
over the elements in this Matrix we have
10 to 5 11
10 2 5 11
so I'm gonna print a and I'm going to print a
DOT T. If you want to transpose The Matrix use the T
attribute from numpy.
So let me run this.
And let me run that.
Okay.
So just like we saw in.
vs code
Now I'm going to multiply this. I'm going to go NP dot Matt
multiply.
and I am going to get
a DOT t and a
which will give us the Matrix.
One two five seven. Okay, this one exactly. So we'll
get a third Matrix.
one two five seven five one two
five
seven five
one two five